okay today I'm going to talk to you
about static electricity
so before we know about static
electricity just a little reminder about
atomic structure so in an atom if we
remember we have the in the nucleus we
have protons and neutrons which remember
protons are positive and neutrons are
neutral and around the outside we have
electrons now this is important when
we're thinking about static electricity
because when you rub two insulating
materials together that is an insulating
material is something which does not
conduct electricity when we rub two
insulating materials together electrons
are transferred from one thing to
another only ever our electrons transfer
the protons and neutrons because they're
in the nucleus here they are never
transferred it's only ever electrons
that are transferred during static
electricity so let's imagine this let's
imagine I've got a balloon and I've
rubbed the balloon against this person's
hair so as you rub these two insulating
materials together electrons are
transferred from one way to the other
from one material to the other so the
balloon because the electrons have been
transferred this way has become
negatively charged and this person's
hair has become positively charged the
reason why the hair has become
positively charged is because the it's
lost these negative electrons it hasn't
lost any protons it's only lost
electrons so now it's it's positively
charged so this is why what if we're off
if I was to zoom in onto a couple of
strands of her hair right now this
person's hair I can see I'd see that
they were both positively charged
because they've lost electrons now comes
for the next important piece of
information
if we've got two things of the same
charge they will always repel each other
whereas if we have two things of the
same or of the opposite charge they will
attract each other and this is a really
important part of static electricity so
if we go back to thinking about this
person's hair which is now positively
charged if this was two strands of her
hair we could see that they would repel
each other and try and get away from
each other as best they can this is why
after you have statically charged her
hair it will stand up like this because
each hair is trying to repel the other
one where is repelling the other one so
that is how static electricity works in
this particular case let's see another
example so let's imagine I've got my
negatively charged balloon negatively
charged remember because it's had loads
of electrons transferred into it because
we've rubbed these two insulating
materials together and I start to bring
this balloon close to this wall so the
wall like the wall is made of matter so
it contains protons neutrons and
electrons because it contains atoms it's
made up of atoms so what happens is as
we start to bring the balloon closer to
the wall these electrons in the surface
of the wall are repelled because we've
got the negative electrons in this
balloon this negatively charged balloons
is going to repel these electrons this
means because all these electrons have
now left the surface of the wall the
wall now is positively charged this
means that if we bring this balloon even
closer to the wall it is in fact going
to stick to the wall because we have the
positively charged wall
being attracted to the negatively
charged balloon so that's how we can
actually induce a charge okay the next
thing we need to know about is earthing
so sometimes now apologies my picture of
a car this is a not going to be the
greatest car ever so sometimes you can
your car can get charged can get subtly
charged so it could be the robbing of
your clothes against the seats that kind
of thing and so as a result your car
could get a it could get a certain
charge now this could potentially be
dangerous because if you went to refuel
your car there could be a sudden
discharge of this of this static charge
and the electrons could suddenly flow
flow out of the car causing a spark and
if it was in a petrol station it could
cause an explosion so as a result you
need objects need to be birthed so
certain objects need to be earned
now what this means is some cars or cars
can have this little wire at the back
that connects to the ground so often
it's made of copper as long as it's a
conductor that connects it to the to the
ground or to the earth and so this
charge can flow out and not build up so
by earthing this car then we're not
going to create a spark by a sudden
discharge of this of this negative
charge and instead it can flow out
through the conductor and in C the
ground the reason why the charge can
flow directly through the wheels is that
the wheels are made of rubber and
therefore they are insulators so
electricity can't flow through it so
just to go over the main points static
electricity is when electrons are
transferred when two insulating
materials are rub
together the object of the electrons are
transferred to becomes negative the
objective the electrons are transferred
from becomes positive
remember there's loads of phenomenon
that they could talk about in an exam
which you to do with either attraction
between oppositely charged things or
repulsion and also what earthing is is
when we connect a charged object to the
ground using a conductor so the charge
can flow out and we don't have a sudden
discharge and potentially an explosion
thank you